le monde du ski et rien ne vaut la
descente de l'acheter
parce qu'on soit qu'elle exige tout du
long n'a pas d'égal sur le circuit
si la descente le plus dangereux ce qui
existe
c'est la brise et pas mal de rêve de
carrière et de personnes mais c'est
aussi sa difficulté qui nous permet de
nous surpasser
la différence entre lâchera effet les
autres courses c'est sûrement schneck
le monde cherche à remporter cette
course pour pouvoir entrer dans
l'histoire du ski alpin allait devenir
une légende de ce sport on est prêt à
risquer notre vie pour ça on est prêt à
tout pour remporter la strive
[Musique]
il faut départ de lâche trahison n'a
plus le droit de reculer on sait que
c'est le moment de tout donner coûte que
coûte en tant que skieur professionnel
on vit pour ce genre de moment décisif
où ans après tu as tout donné les
risques que cela comporte en sachant
pertinemment que les choses peuvent très
vite mal tourner
[Musique]
the first out on découvre kitzbuehl on
n'est pas très rassuré comme mon premier
départ j'étais terrifiée
notamment à cause des anciens qui
m'avait dit la veille lente ne des faits
pas des affaires ça nous évitera de
devoir tout ranger demain si tu finis à
l'hôpital
la première fois qu'on passe la ligne
d'arrivée on est content d'avoir survécu
mais on appréhende encore le prochain
départ
[Musique]
deux matchs traille fait la course la
plus redoutable du circuit de la coupe
du monde
la difficulté de la course et elle que
l'on doit donner le meilleur de soi-même
se surpasser pour repousser toutes ses
limites sauf un
ce qui est comme on me l'a jamais fait
auparavant
c'est sûrement pour ça que je vais
[Musique]
rentrer enfin dans l'histoire en
devenant le premier américain à gagner
lâche life ça c'était mon enfant que
j'attendais
remporté cette course en 2003 a été un
grand moment pour moi malheureusement il
n'y avait pas d'autres chiens sur le
podium didier cuche était 2e et le
norvégien kjetil andre aamodt et des
troisièmes du coup le lendemain tout ce
qu'il y avait à la une du journal aux
deschiens c'était un énorme samedi noir
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça n'a rien à voir avec les autres
courses de la coupe du monde finir ici
en un seul morceau c'est déjà une
victoire en soi c'est sa caisse
c'est la difficulté du parcours qui a
fait la réputation de la streif
[Applaudissements]
petit pull c'est de l'adrénaline à
l'état pur peu importe le résultat mais
si vous arrivez à l'avenir les gens vous
diront le fait d'avoir eu le courage de
faire cette course chapeau
[Applaudissements]
ce qui me motive à kitzbuehl c'est
l'ambiance survoltée les gens sont là
pour voir un vrai spectacle ce qu'ils
veulent c'est voir des skieurs qui n'ont
pas froid aux yeux en tant qu'athlète on
est au centre du spectacle
on est pour ainsi dire des gladiateurs
et tout le monde a les yeux rivés sur
il en faut du courage pour la descendre
pour affronter chaque virage tête la
première et en venir à bout trouver le
courage de faire ça c'est difficile
death pire des moments d'adrénaline à
150 km heure c'est incroyable être
skieurs alpins est un privilège
[Musique]
la bombe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quant au liban
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut absolument que l'on renforce les
muscles de soutien on doit travailler
davantage sur la stabilité
[Musique]
il faut intensifier l'entraînement ses
abdos muscles dorsaux tout doit y passer
non m peu importe la trajectoire que tu
choisiras de prendre sur la piste cet
hiver tu devrais être capable de tenir
deux minutes et demie à pleine vitesse
si tu veux atteindre des capacités
maximales le jour j ai créé l'exploit il
faut que tu sois au top de sa forme
physique et mentale
[Musique]
jamais wimax ça pèse 50 kilos
je veux voir plus de stabilité travail
ou moins ses pectoraux
ok c'est bien bon boulot
aller avant serre les dents
oui aller
allez
lâche toi tu donnes tout ce que tu as à
l'est
[Musique]
wallin s'entraîner durant l'été fait
partie du tout
si on tombe aussi on se blesse le jour j
on ne peut pas s'empêcher de penser que
si on s'était plus entraîné ce ne serait
pas arrivé plus on est entraîné moins on
risque sur la piste
[Musique]
allez un dernier
je
[Musique]
la même gamme est mondialement connue
pour les courses de ski qui l'accueille
ce n'est pas comme un terrain de
football que l'on prépare juste une
semaine avant si tu n'as rien à ciel
ouvert
le club de ski de kitzbühel s'en occupe
à longueur d'année il faut constamment
s'occuper du terrain pour qu'il reste en
bon état
les fidèles et barrières tout ce qu on
nous prêtait
on se rend pas compte du travail que ça
représente
[Musique]
voir son nom sur une cabine à kitzbuehl
c'est encore mieux que d'avoir son
étoile sur le walk of fame d'hollywood
jeunes
applaudissent et bien fort dominique
paries
l'italien le plus rapide que la shta
effet connu
[Applaudissements]
et nous invité d'honneur du jour aksel
lund svindal et franz klammer
remporté le super g à kitzbühel c'est
super j'en peux plus
je rêverais de gagner la descente de
kitzbühel ce jour-là n'est pas encore
arrivé mais chaque année j'ai les yeux
rivés sur cette course
c'est agréable de profiter de la streif
en est et nord de ses ressources et au
calme avant d'y vivre des moments de
folie l'hiver fait avant de se retrouver
face à 50000 personnes qui nous acclame
tout simplement parce qu'on a fini la
course en un seul mandat
[Applaudissements]
harper une fournissons doit absolument
retrouver notre état d'esprit de
guerrier
tout ce que l'on doit garder en tête
c'est de ne rien lâcher
d'un côté on se dit de ne pas faire
l'imbécile mais de l'autre on sait bien
que si l'on veut que ça paye on est
obligé de prendre des risques et
c'est là que tout se joue doit maîtriser
notre trajectoire à la perfection pour
prendre autant de vitesse que possible
dans le virage
puis on se rend compte qu'il irait en
beauce c'est qu'on voit même pas la fin
du virage on essaie de se laisser porter
pour maximiser la vitesse mais après on
a un mal fou à prendre la dernière porte
[Musique]
- cc une fois que la voie est bien
dégagé ils ont foncé vers la compression
dutil tous
passage le plus rapide de la course là
il faut essayer d'être aussi détendu que
possible sur c'est ce qui m'avait la
fatigue et continue à se battre de
toutes ses forces avant d'apercevoir la
ligne droite
ce n'est ni la viande un moment dépassé
la ville d'agde
sous un tonnerre d'applaudissements
en ski je n'ai jamais rien ressenti de
plus gratifiant que d'arriver au bout
lâche trahi
star je demande une concentration
extrême le terrain est glissant plein de
bosses et les faits sont si bien qu'on
n'a pas le temps de gamberger
[Applaudissements]
la sortie du jeu talking qui déterminent
la vitesse qu'on aura sur le passage à
plat
effet qu'un gagnant 2 km heure sur cette
section on gagne deux dixièmes de
seconde sur le plat
et donc primordial de bien maîtriser ce
passage du jeune
[Musique]
prendre de la vitesse à la sortie de ce
virage en dévers et décisif pour le
reste de la course
demain lama aux fallait est un passage
dangereux elle vous pousse dans vos
retranchements et la moindre erreur
fatale
la différence entre l'âge traille fait
les autres pistes de l'année du monde
sait que tout se joue dès les 30
premières secondes ici les dés sont
jetés dès les premiers mètres
[Musique]
ne pas se laisser envahir par la peur
sur la streif
si on s'est perdu d'avancé on doit sans
ces corps et âme dans la descente sans
se poser la moindre question ce qu'on
doit faire rire qu'il restait aux
commandes skis
avant je croyais que pour être skieurs
alpins il fallait être un colosse d'une
centaine de kilos
une vraie armoire à glace
[Musique]
la rendra les 81 kg ont changé ma vision
des choses
en fait le plus important pour devenir
skieur alpin c'est la maîtrise technique
ski alpin la seule façon s'entraîner
efficacement c'est de faire toutes les
courses du circuit de la coupe du monde
ce sont le seul parcours qui permettent
de se préparer efficacement d'une course
à l'autre est lé seul parcours où le
postier la montagne de haut en bas
on doit skier en été et en automne ou
l'hiver avec toutes les courses et les
déplacements on n'a pas le temps de
s'entraîner
on doit être prêt avant l'hiver sinon on
devra loupé des courses
alors si l'on veut gagner des titres on
ne peut pas se le permettre car on
perdra des points
la vitesse ne se résume pas une question
de kilomètres heure c'est plutôt la
rapidité et les ans avec lesquels on
arrive à gérer les différents obstacles
qui se présentent
deux êtres humains c'est réussir à
trouver l'équilibré parfait entre
vitesse et technique
hello monster importe le genre de
compétition dont il s'agit on veut
toujours en sortir vainqueur
[Applaudissements]
une course automobile c'est un peu comme
une course de ski alpin on a la vitesse
les capacités requises pour gagner sont
similaires
savoura maîtrisé sa trajectoire
bien ne faire qu'un avec la piste
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
les forces chez les sensations sont très
similaires dans les deux sports
ce qui différencie ces deux sports l'un
de l'autre c'est la possibilité ou non
de voir son adversaire pendant la hausse
et gagne
[Applaudissements]
marcel hircher et moi-même concours ont
tous les deux pour la coupe du monde
mais il est plus slalom et slalom géant
et moi descente et super g dames
subsiste speed run
[Applaudissements]
en fait c'est un peu comme si on
s'affrontait dans des arènes différentes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah mais je me connais je sais que je
n'aime pas perdre mais ce n'est rien
comparé à marseille chez lui c'est
maladif il déteste ça
[Musique]
contrôler quelque chose d'incontrôlable
c'est exactement ce que l'on cherche à
faire en descendant les pistes de qui
brûlent à 140 km h
le pire dans tout ça c'est qu'on en veut
toujours plus
arrivé en bas de la liste savoir qu'on a
donné le meilleur de soi même et se
retrouver sur le podium c'est une
sensation comparable
déjà fini deuxième et cinquième à
plusieurs reprises mais remporter kitbul
ce doit être incroyable je n'ai pas
encore eu l'occasion de le vivre mais si
ça arrive un jour alors je pourrai enfin
être
difficile de se retrouver sur la touche
et de ne rien pouvoir faire il faut
prendre sur soi entre patient et avoir
confiance en l'avenir
[Musique]
si l'on veut se remettre de ce genre de
blessure il faut être extrêmement fort
mentalement
quand on aime ce sport quand on aime
dévaler les pistes des ski alors on ne
se pose pas de questions on se bat avec
le sourire on fait ce qu'il faut pour
récupérer au plus vite à revenir sur le
devant de la scène
les blessures font partie de la vie d'un
sportif de haut niveau mais je pense
avoir donné en la matière et j'espère ne
plus avoir à repasser par là
et ça fait partie du jeu ce qui est une
succession de hauts et de bas il est des
périodes où on se sent top-ten forme où
on n'arrête pas de progresser tout nous
sourit puis on fait un mauvais mouvement
en se blesse et on est forfait pour le
reste de la saison pouvoir plus certains
ne reviennent jamais après il assure
aujourd'hui encore je regarde la
descente de kitzbühel comme un petit
garçon
c'est vraiment une course incroyable et
chacun de nous sait comme elle est
dangereuse
le ski de compétition et dangereux
[Musique]
mexes imax est ici c'est parce qu'on est
amis
lorsque nous étions à l'école cette
rivalité entre nous on existait déjà
tout comme nos différences qui quand je
faisais un backflip il en faisait depuis
il prenait toujours plus de risques que
moi mais j'ai toujours été légèrement
meilleures au niveau de la technique et
on a fini par s'éloigner mais max est
resté téméraire rien ne l'arrête c'est
un vrai casse cou
et nous voulons réuni slalomeurs et des
sandales
s'entraîner ensemble nous permet de
comparer nos conditions physiques et de
comprendre ce que chacun de nous doit
travailler davantage
at least remis personnellement je trouve
ça bien plus drôle que de soulever des
poids toute la journée de faire des
exercices seul dans mon coin
[Musique]
seul homme c'est de la folie il faut
être rapide et agile
l'objectif est de réduire la distance
d'une porte à l'autre à 9 mètres ce qui
est extrêmement difficile
ça si l'on veut concourir au niveau
international on doit avoir à cette
puissance aux réserves pour faire des
accélérations
[Musique]
et en louer un tel niveau ne peut être
atteint qu'avec la pratique d'un
entraînement aussi variés que possible
entraîner un slalomeur et un descendeur
ensemble c'est un vrai challenge
[Musique]
certes king dans leur façon de skier est
complètement différente c'est la
technique face à la vitesse
n'est travailler ensemble leur permet de
s'améliorer
pourquoi
[Musique]
je me souviens qu'il ya deux ans tout le
monde était persuadé que si je
concourais je gagnerai c'est super de se
dire que les gens vous croit capable de
réaliser un tel exploit
tout comme la taille frais le slalom de
kitzbühel a écrit des légendes
et selon moi l'ambiance qui règne sur
cette épreuve est tout aussi
impressionnante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'année
être couronné vainqueur à kitzbuehl
c'est s'assurer une certaine place
d'honneur
de cette pression à cette peur de
l'échec
il faut être capable de gérer la
pression sinon c'est peine perdue
[Musique]
il ya cinquante mille personnes sur
place et deux millions devant leur
télévision rien qu en autriche
c'est aussi ça qui nous pousse à tout
donner sur la piste
[Musique]
aussi incompréhensible que cela puisse
paraître j'arrive à défier la gravité
encore et encore après coup je me
demande vraiment comment j'ai fait je
dois avouer que ça me donne la chair de
poule
parce que j'en ai vraiment aucune idée
[Applaudissements]
et qu'est ce que c'est tout comme la
descente le slalom de kitzbühel a révélé
des grands skieurs tels que omar
stenmark tomba la bomba marc girardelli
aujourd'hui plus personne ne gagne
descente et cela même la même année à
part dans les années 60 jean claude
killy qui est l'un des plus grands
skieurs de tous les temps a réussi cet
exploit ce serait incroyable que ça se
reproduise
en 1937 c'était la strive qui ouvraient
la marche c'était la première épreuve à
l'époque c'était différent l'objectif
était juste de descendre la pente tant
bien que mal malgré le manque
d'équipements et de pistes de ski
chaotique où se met les nerfs mais
pierre
même comme ça les spectateurs se
précipitaient pour voir qu'il y avait le
courage de s'y lancer le ski des années
50 était dominée par l'équipe légendaire
de kitzbuehel semés sur ses skieurs de
kitzbuehl parmi lesquels se trouvaient
en dehors moche d'horreur et toni sailer
l'ambiance est à son apogée ici sur la
strive la plus grande bouffe dans lequel
g et voici le favori under molterer de
kits bull le voici qui descend la strive
telle une furie et s'élance sur la
dernière ligne droite pour passer la
ligne d'arrivée en un temps record
ça sent la victoire pour lui et c'est
tout ou de toni sailer de s'élancer dans
ladite souricière c'est cette piste 3900
mètres de long et parsemé de pierre
moins rapides comme le tireur à la
sortie du stade rennais sa précision le
propulse en tête du classement avec un
pic de vitesse à plus de 100 kilomètres
heure tony c'est l'un remporte là stripe
aux 2 47 points
[Musique]
et
dans les années 60 avec l'arrivée des
célébrités
qu'ils acquièrent une autre dimension
ça devient un lieu de fête où les jolies
filles se bousculent depuis rien n'a
changé
ouais
[Musique]
et
ensuite il ya une case france cette
légende a remporté la streif ou quatre
fois et a longtemps détenu le record
a night in sable ils ont les années 70
un nouvel autrichien fait son entrée sur
la strive franz klammer sa façon de
skier a révolutionné la strife il lui a
valu de remporter pas mal de courses en
75 t il la gagne pour la première fois
et conserve son titre trois ans
d'affilée
[Applaudissements]
j'avais tenté de lui imaginer kitzbuehl
à plusieurs reprises mais là je me
trouvais enfin c'était vraiment
incroyable
la mausefalle et le style jungle m'ont
laissé sans voix c'est la meilleure des
centres monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais je n'aurais cru réaliser un temps
record c'était terrible
s'élancer du haut de cette montagne sans
se laisser envahir par la peur ça n'est
pas facile surtout quand on connaît les
risques
[Musique]
c'est très dur
c'en est presque dangereux effet à
l'heure c'est assurément la course la
plus techniques du circuit
tout y est bon trade virages en dévers
courbe légère passage à plat c'est une
course très exigeante
j'ai réussi à la remporter trois fois de
suite avant de ne plus rien faire
pendant sept ans sept longues années
sans rien faire
et et puis en 84 j'ai senti que c'était
mon année j'ai tout fait pour gagner
j'ai retrouvé l'agressivité de mes
débuts sur la streif j'ai fait ce qu'il
fallait et je les remporter à nouveau
des gains avec ma victoire olympique
c'est le moment le plus marquant de ma
carrière
et voici franz klammer qui tente de
prendre de la vitesse
on a dû lui dire dans l'oreillette
d'accélérer pour sortir du style yang
avec plus de puissance voyons un peu son
temps intermédiaire wahou une demi
seconde d'avancé une demi seconde plus
rapide de cathomen
les spectateurs sont survoltés alors que
franz klammer finissent la descente
va-t-il créer l'exploit oui oh oui le 02
82 de 0.82 regardez comme elle est
contente très content
c'est la victoire de clameur à kitzbuehl
était incroyable la marée humaine de
spectateurs qui le poussait dans tous
les sens tout le monde voulait le
féliciter sur la ligne d'arrivée cette
victoire de clameurs en 1984 a fait la
fierté de l'autriche toute entière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette année là ma façon de skier a
tellement impressionné que cette course
est devenue le moment fort de ma
carrière piquer ma meilleure course
regardez-moi ça se frite est encore plus
rapide que werner fritz strobl détient
toujours le temps record réalisé sur la
strive il a frôlé la barre hier pognon
un peu son tour intermédiaire 12 02 50
c'était en 1997 le parcours de l'earth
berg est un peu plus direct s'il a
réussi à gagner quatre ou cinq secondes
sur tous les chronos
mais aujourd'hui son temps est toujours
le meilleur
hermann maier c'est lui qui lui a
succédé sur la streif c'était assurément
le meilleur skieur au début des années
mais attention hermann maier attention
ralenti je me rappelle bien de cette
période il était au top de sa forme
c'était l'homme à battre
après avoir remporté de nombreuses
courses et le super jeu danone calmes
ils gagnent enfin sa première descente
sur la streif et voici herman mayer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
kitzbühel c'est exceptionnel hermann
maier il était simplement incroyable
après sa terrible chute personne ne
savait si leur marche vers un jour et
malgré la douleur il a fait son grand
retour en 2003 et a surpris tout le
monde le premier c'est comme s'il
n'avait jamais quitté la piste il vous a
fait un sacré sceau
du revenu et il a gagné le super g dames
s câble c'est quand même exceptionnel je
suis tire mon chapeau
c'est un moment particulièrement
important pour ma carrière
l'autre chose qu'il ya eu en 2003 et
bien c'est ma victoire
je suis devenu le premier américain à
gagner lâche trahi
ce jour là j'ai senti que la victoire
était pour moi et j'ai tout donné ta
rendra meilleur temps intermédiaire
je me suis fait un peu peur dans la
traverse j'ai pris une bosse que je
n'avais pas vu j'ai même failli faire le
grand écart mais je me suis redresser et
j'ai réussi à finir en tête du
classement j'étais sur un petit nuage
quand j'ai gagné c'était juste faut
c'est de loin le plus beau jour de ma
carrière de skieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oh
[Musique]
c'est comme dans les bols
en 2004 j'ai fait ma meilleure semaine à
kitzbuehl
suis arrivé là-bas au top de ma forme
j'avais gagné un super g la veille
j'étais prêt à gagner à nouveau chez ski
avec détermination et avec confiance
j'ai pris la tête du classement et je me
suis dit que c'était dans la poche enfin
c'était sans compter sur stephan
eberharter
j'ai décidé de prendre des risques pays
s'est lancé dans cette descente gonflé à
bloc ils avaient tous été agile rapide
qui était bien en rythme et extrêmement
un passif tous les éléments étaient
réunis pour qu'il remporte la course son
temps intermédiaire était bien meilleur
que le maire et je me disais mais
ralentie à l'est soit sympa l'essm a
remporté ma deuxième strike
je crois que ce jour là il a explosé
tous les records
[Applaudissements]
un
grand bravo à toi stéphane c'était une
sacrée descente
[Musique]
son tour regarde en arrière et couvre
des skieurs tels que karl schranz et
franz klammer vainqueur de la strive à
quatre reprises on se dit que personne
n'est capable de battre de tels
résultats et pourtant le suisse didier
cuche a fait un quart remporté la streif
à cinq reprises
lors de mon premier départ à kitzbuehl
j'étais terrifiée croire des cinq
meilleurs skieurs du circuit venait
d'être envoyé à l'hôpital
et je me suis dit comment veux tu t'en
sortir si même les meilleurs réchauffer
je n'avais qu'une envie c'était de
reculer de la ligne de départ et
redescendre de la hanter les 80 dollars
d'ailleurs la première fois que j'ai
passé la ligne d'arrivée j'ai levé les
bras comme si j'avais gagné la course
en 98 j'ai remporté la première victoire
de ma carrière avec l'ach treichl
j'étais très élevé je ne pensais pas
être capable de skier cette piste aussi
vite
après ça j'ai dû attendre dix ans pour
renouveler l'exploit en 2008 tous deux
ans après en 2010 j'ai remporté deux
courses à kitzbuehl le super g et la
distribuer
tout en 2011 la météo était idéale léger
gagnait sous le soleil avec près d'une
seconde d'avancé
[Musique]
j'étais vraiment fier de moi
et j'ai enfin dans mi temps
c'était ma course parfaite
mais peu importe la durée d'une série de
victoires on se rapproche chaque jour un
peu plus de son terme et à force de voir
des skieurs devoir mettre fin à leur
carrière à cause de chute violente
dispute comme a cartonné albrecht ou
gros gadins
toussaint ça vous fait vraiment
réfléchir et on se dit qu'on est peut
être le prochain sur la liste
en 2012 j'ai décidé de concourir à
kitzbuehl pour une toute dernière fois
et deux jours avant de prendre le départ
j'ai annoncé que je prendrai ma retraite
à la fin de la saison
[Applaudissements]
après c'est vrai que je me suis mis
beaucoup de pression
mais je tenais vraiment finir sur une
dernière victoire
et après coup j'ai remercié la montagne
et toute la région de kébili jove kembo
[Musique]
youri dany de chin je suis un skieur
biélorusse pour moi tout a commencé ici
à minsk où il ya des montagnes ni même
la neige
ça peut paraître étrange mais c'est vrai
tu as commencé quand j'ai vu hermann
maier et stefan eberharter descendre la
strive
tickets sports
je suis persuadé qu'un jour je réussirai
à devenir une légende comme eux
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
savoir ce que je vaux
ski alpin c'est le meilleur moyen de le
découvrir
quelques jours l'hiver sera là on
repartira en direction des alpes où l'on
pourra retourner skier fr de la descente
ça c'est moi en train de conduire
et voilà
je suis regonflé à bloc pour la nouvelle
saison parce que je veux participer à la
coupe du monde
ne vont pas les moyens financiers
d'aller au canada ou aux états unis mais
nous avons l'europe
je n'ai aucun moyen de m'entraîner en
descente avant val gardena pour moi tout
commence là
l'argent est un vrai problème on ne peut
pas aller au canada et aux états unis
les billets d'avion coûte bien trop cher
j'ai demandé à la fédération biélorusse
de nous aider mais ils ne peuvent pas
bons
on aussi c'était au début de la saison
la pression monte c'est quoi ce qu on se
demande quel est notre niveau on le sait
[Applaudissements]
le chemin vers la coupe du monde est
long j'ai commencé le ski à 18 mois j'ai
fait ma première course à cinq ans la
première course est pièce à 15 ans je
suis arrivé en coupe d'europe et en
coupe du monde
et les choses sont devenues sérieuses
j'ai commencé à me mesurer aux meilleurs
every time chaque fois c'est la même
chose il fait froid on n'a pas le temps
de manger
et encore moins de se laver les cheveux
nous ne sommes que deux dans l'équipe
mais moi mais ma mère nathalie pour
survivre sur le circuit on est obligé de
demander à nos amis de nous héberger
même parfois de nous donner un peu
d'argent pour que l'on puisse remettre
de l'essence et continuer notre route
vers les différentes courses de la coupe
du monde
choisi un travail difficile je sais que
c'est aussi dur pour elle que pour moi
le moindre problème déclenché une guerre
mondiale
parfois c'est vraiment difficile de
discuter avec ma mère
mais je les aime quand même
moi mon fils est extrêmement doué en
fait je crois que c'est le meilleur
descendeur du monde bost d'art diaw
[Rires]
faire partie des meilleurs à six
exigences on doit travailler sa
technique tester ses skis pour savoir
lesquels utilisé pour quelques courses
choisir son phare ou encore ses
chaussures de ski si l'on veut se
mesurer aux meilleurs tout cela a
beaucoup d'importance oui tout ça parce
qu'on les hait devait faire de mon fils
sont plaints de paires de skis
différentes peut-être 20 on fils lui il
en a cure c'est moi qui prépare six qui
tous les jours
le stress m'empêche de dormir la nuit
alors autant de rendre utile
[Musique]
c'est très difficile de préparer des
skis toute une nuit
chez la femme terminateur
tout à fait ça
l'airé rare au sommet sa vitesse et
d'une centaine de sorties mètres par
seconde sans les conseils d'un
professionnel on n'a aucune chance ou la
situation doit changer on a besoin
d'argent et faire un bon résultat à
kitzbuehl pourrait aider
h trail qui me donne l'opportunité de
faire mes preuves et de m'améliorer ce
qui fait
pour l'instant ce n'est pas très
prometteur
les prévisions météo sont mauvaises
c'est déjà arrivé avant
en 88 c'était pareil
tout était vert il n'y avait pas du tout
de neige sur la piste
enfin bon
espérons que la situation s'améliore
on trouvera une solution ça ira
je suis tout de même déçu
ça fait cinq semaines que la température
trop élevée fait fondre la neige de lens
berkane jusqu'à à travers ce site à
cause du foehn c'est un vent qui vient
du sud c'est vraiment dommage parce que
seule la météo pose problème il a part
ça la piste est parfaitement préparé
pour le début de la course tout ce que
l'on demande c'est de nuit assez froide
histoire de faire tenir la neige deux
autres balles
nous sommes lundi 13 et selon le
bulletin météo du jour il fera frais
mais pas froid pas assez pour que la
neige artificielle tiennent
deux journées froides la ferai tenir
mais on ne peut pas prendre ce risque si
l'on veut arriver à quelque chose il
nous faut une solution maintenant des
suggestions
je sais qu'on préférerait tous éviter ça
mais il va falloir ramener de la neige
par hélicoptère
on
n'a pas le choix c'est la seule solution
il n'ya pas d'autre alternative
espérons que les gens du coin soient
compréhensifs
ils savent que s'ils ont fait ça c'est
pour une bonne raison
ça marchera ça va être du boulot mais on
s'en sortir
mais matt et chauffe internet une autre
public du monde entier s'attend à ce que
la hausse bare buchan te fasse partie de
la course c'est l'un des secteurs les
plus attendus de la course auto
n'incarne et bien allons-y il n'y a plus
de temps à perdre
il faut deux équipes par hélicoptère une
pour charger et l'autre pour décharger
il va falloir être rapide et efficace
mais je n'ai aucun doute là dessus on y
arrivera
la distance à parcourir en hélicoptère
est d'environ 900 m
principalement à l'horizontale est il
faut compter trois minutes de vol en
hélicoptère et on devrait pouvoir
transporter un mètre cube de neige par
minute de vol
bien sûr il faut prendre en compte le
coût des opérations ainsi que la
température extérieure qui pourrait tout
compromettre est ce que l'on doit
dépenser autant d'argent pour quelque
chose qui pourrait ne pas fonctionner
est ce que ça vaut le coup
personnellement je pense que oui
là où je veux quand t'es doit à tout
prix faire partie de la lenga on ne peut
pas faire ça
[Musique]
on
la neige est amené par hélicoptère puis
on la dépose sur la housse bergues c'est
la première fois qu'on fait ça mais rien
n'est trop beau pour cette course
la température de la nuit dernière était
encore trop élevé il a fait 10 degrés
sur la hausse peur quand heures
maintenant il faut croiser les doigts
pour que le front d'air froid arrive
comme prévu ces noms tous nos efforts
n'ont servi à rien
[Musique]
en
tant qu'athlète on le voit pas l'envers
du décor
ne vois pas du tout ce que le club de
ski de kitzbühel doit faire tous les
efforts nécessaires pour organiser la
bonne can chaque année
salut chérie c'est à lui n'est ni le que
six semaines avant qu'on se revoie
ouais je sais qui tu bull vient d'être
confirmée à super et cette histoire de
neige alors on se pose tous des
questions à ce sujet parce que c'est
encore vert à des endroits mais c'est
bon
c'est kitzbuehl ils sont capables de
déplacer des montagnes pour que la
course ait lieu
apparemment tout le monde en europe fait
des paris entre l'actuel et moi
parce qu'on est premier et deuxième au
classement général
heureusement que vous êtes de bons amis
ouais enfin on est amis dans la vie mais
mis sur la piste
de tuer les proches des prochaines
courses vont être importantes il y avait
une gaine et juste après ces prises bull
je suis vraiment pressé d'y être
la bataille commence à eric
je pense que j'ai toutes mes chances
cette année tout va se jouer dans la
tête du début de l'année j'étais pas sûr
de l'état de mon genou mais maintenant
que je sais que tout va bien je suis
confiant ce
ougna les combats à kitzbühel on doit
être sûr que le jeu en vaut la chandelle
c'est ça ça dépend des risques que l'on
décide de prendre
[Musique]
svindal est probablement le plus
téméraire lee miller fait son retour
cette année ils veulent gagner tout
autant que moi mais pour ça il faut
s'entraîner dur
dit au revoir salut les nids salut logan
bisou au revoir
mais aussi à bientôt
allez au revoir
les parcours tels que celui de la strife
n'ont pas été créés par l'homme ils se
sont formés au fil des années le
problème du coup ce qu'il n'y a pas de
zone de sécurité intégrée si bien qu'il
faut installer des filets de sécurité
un jour avant le début de la course on
commence à tout installer on commence
par mettre les filets de sécurité
annette puis les bennett lors d'une
chute vous est projeté avec une violence
telle que tout cela est indispensable
la sécurité des skieurs dépens de tous
les dispositifs de sécurité qu'on
installe
[Musique]
malheureusement même comme ça une chute
finit souvent mal
[Musique]
en soi une course n'est pas dangereux
chaque course a ses particularités ses
difficultés mais c'est la façon dont on
skie qui détermine si la situation est
risqué ou non à l'époque il disposait
des bottes de paille tout du long mais
il finissait par gelé et devenir dur
ça venait à foncer dans un mur en
briques
[Musique]
et les spectateurs qui voulait
absolument voir la course de près avait
la mauvaise idée de venir se coller aux
barrières
maintenant mes défilés sur trois rangées
partout et on oblige les spectateurs à
rester derrière les protections
à l'époque les gens n'avaient pas
conscience du danger que cela
représentait
vous
emotionnellement oswald est jalonnée de
cailloux si on se trompe de direction
comme ce japonais ont volent par-dessus
la barrière
je ne me souviens pas de ma chute
je n'ai vu qu'une seule fois à la
télévision
mais ça avait l'air aussi douloureux que
ce que je ressens en ce moment
c'est une chute très violente
du mal au crâne
ou cou et au dos
je me suis blessé au genou aussi mais ça
ne devrait pas trop poser de problème
j'ai démarré normalement
puis j'ai mis trop de poids sur
l'arrière j'ai dérapé des chaussées et
atterrit dans le filet c'est tout ce
dont je me souviens
[Musique]
dérape chute et il retombe se rendre à
une fois dans le filet j'ai regardé à ma
droite et j'ai vu qu'il ne lui restait
qu'un bout de la main je me suis dit
c'est quoi cette blague j'ai voulu
attraper mon bâton mais je n'ai pas
réussi parce que je n'avais plus demain
est ce que ça valait la peine de prendre
ces risques on est prêt à tout pour
kitzbuehl absolument tout se trouvait en
haut de cette liste rien n'est plus
incroyable c'est la descente par
excellence mais je continuerai de la
descendre coûte que coûte
participent à cette course on devrait
j'ai toujours dit que s'ils ont
participé à cette course on appartenait
à une autre catégorie de personnel
aucune personne sensée ne ferais ça
si on fait cette course c'est forcément
plus quelque chose ne tourner pas rond
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ce qui intéresse les gens
c'est de voir des chutes c'est triste à
dire mais malheureusement c'est pour
cette raison qu'on a de plus en plus de
spectateurs
[Applaudissements]
en tant qu'organisateur on fait tout
pour éviter qu'il y ait des chutes on
veut que la compétition se passe du
mieux possible pour les skieurs et qu'il
passe la ligne d'arrivée
[Musique]
au portillon de départ les skieurs
savent très bien ce qu'ils risquent ils
savent ce qu'ils font ce sont des
professionnels
ce qui est malsain c'est tous ces gens
qui espèrent voir une chute juste parce
qu'ils ont envie de voir du spectacle et
le pire c'est que ces personnes sont les
mêmes qui poussent des cris d'effroi
quand ça arrive un peu de respect pour
cette discipline et ses skieurs serait
le bienvenu
il ya quelques années on a fait un test
on a équipé un mannequin puis on l'a
lancé dans le style à une vitesse de 110
km/heure
en faisant en sorte qu'il atterrisse
dans le filet
et on a découvert que lorsqu'il earth
est le fils est à 90 degrés il était
exposé à 14 h
si ça nous arrivait ça nous tueraient
c'est pour éviter cela qu'on met les
filets annette dans le fret et les
filets bennett c'est juste en face le
fait de disposer ses deux fils et en
quinconce et à distance rapprochée
permis de réduire l'impact des chocs
[Musique]
il faut accepter un parcours tel qu'il
est mais peu importe sa difficulté il
faut skier avec agressivité ce qui est
dangereux c'est de ce qui est sur la
défensive
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'avant la
course tous les skieurs examine la piste
et qu'on n'a jamais fait personne reculé
du portillon de départ est une fois
qu'ils se retrouvent là haut leur
décision est prise depuis longtemps et
ils ont conscience de ce qu'ils font
bien sûr que cette course est dangereuse
mais le ski alpin c'est toujours
dangereux va tester son
latéral c'est de loin le pire de tous
c'est la pire chose qui puisse arriver
un siège
avant d'avoir mon accident je ne
réfléchissais pas au risque que je
prenais sur une piste de ski
cross j'avais vu ce qui était arrivé à
daniel albrecht et j'espérais qu'il s'en
sortirait
mais comme tout skieur dès que j'ai
appris que dany était sorti du coma et
qu'il allait bien j'ai fait en sorte de
ne plus jamais y repenser
il faut essayer d'oublier
aussi vite que possible
en ne daigne c'est la seule façon de
pouvoir continuer à skier
et quand je regarde en arrière je me
demande si les risques que l'on prend en
valent vraiment la peine
hauger 29 ans originaire de bathurst
ailleurs
[Musique]
durant mes premières années sur la
strife je n'avais pas du tout confiance
en moi
et mes résultats étaient mauvais
allez annecy montre-nous un peu de quoi
tu es capable
qu'est ce que tu penses de transport
maintenant que du bien pour être honnête
je ne me souviens absolument de rien
alors je n'ai vraiment pas à me plaindre
[Musique]
mais c'est pas vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
huit ans après la chute de hans nous
sommes retournés sur la streif c'était
la première fois que j allais quand nous
sommes arrivés au passage de la mouse
fallait je suis resté sans voix
c'est un parcours extrêmement exigeant
et difficile
[Musique]
mais un évidement cette chute a marqué
un tournant pour hans sa marqué sa vie
toute entière
[Musique]
quand on regarde les images et
scanographiques de départ on voit que
son état était critique il n'avait que
très peu de chances de s'en sortir en j
pour l'instant facebook
[Musique]
les sept premiers jours ont été décisifs
les premières heures qui ont suivi la
chute de danse ont été extrêmement
critique tout comme les premiers jours
on ne savait pas s'il s'en sortir est
l'un des problèmes étaient cette lésion
qu'il avait au niveau de l'artère
carotide car en cas de thrombose ou
d'embolie cela peut provoquer un avc aux
conséquences dramatiques
[Musique]
après un traumatisme crânien sévère on
est différent chez chaque patient on
note des changements dans le caractère
et latitude
si les secours avaient mis 10 minutes de
plus pour l'amener à l'hôpital en ce
n'aurait jamais survécu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
alors
content d'être de retour parmi nous oui
j'espère que tout ira bien bien sûr que
oui que je n'aurai pas de séquelles
permanentes n'a
j'espère pas
bien sûr on s'est demandé
s'il retrouverait son autonomie j'ai
tout fait pour l'aider pour le soutenir
je vais consacrer toute mon énergie j'ai
essayé de l'aider du mieux possible
quand j'ai recouvré la mémoire mon
physiothérapeute est venu pour que
j'essaie de me lever nds c'est un moment
que je n'oublierai jamais de ma vie
tu es j'étais vraiment effondré pour la
toute première fois
j'ai pris conscience
de ce qui m'était vraiment arrivé
un peu en thérapie ma plus grande
préoccupation était de savoir si je
recouvrerait mes facultés mentales
[Musique]
de first la première fois que j'ai
regardé la vidéo c'était huit ou neuf
mois après mon accident
juste avant de la lancer j'étais
terrifiée
je n'ai pas réussi à me reconnaître dans
la vidéo pour moi c'était juste la chute
sur une personne lambda
c'est tout ce que j'ai ressenti en
regardant la vidéo
[Musique]
avant l'accident ans nous étions égaux
mais évidemment après l'accident nous ne
l'étions plus
et en tant que couple il nous fallait
retrouver cet équilibre
c'est pas facile
et ça ne se fait pas du jour au
lendemain
le fait qu'il soit capable de
reconnaître qu arrêter le ski en
compétition de manière définitive était
la meilleure chose à faire ça a été un
grand pas
c'était très important que monsieur
kruger me parviennent enfin à
reconnaître ses limites
un call flop si j'ai renoncé à la
compétition
c'est parce que mon pied n'étaient plus
en assez bon état
j'ai travaillé dur pendant des mois mais
mon pied ne répondait plus comme avant
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai pris
conscience que je ne serai plus jamais
en mesure de ce qui est à un niveau
professionnel
quand on sait comme le ski alpin peut
être un sport dangereux revenir à un
niveau professionnel était tout sauf une
bonne idée
[Musique]
malgré tout cela je me sens bien et je
remercie la strive de m'avoir laissé en
ville
je peux encore descendre ce parcours
peut-être pas toute vitesse comme avant
mais sur des skis quand même
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire mon rapport à la strive n'a
absolument rien de triste au contraire
j'aurais plutôt tendance à la considérer
comme une vieille amie
malgré tous les efforts déployés par le
club de ski de kitzbühel par souci de
sécurité
la fisa décidé de changer le parcours
est de ne pas faire passer les skieurs
par la traverse pour rejoindre à
oberkampf le point positif c'est que ce
nouveau parcours est un nouveau défi la
course ne sera pas plus facile pour
autant de toute façon on n'a pas le
choix c'est mère nature qui décide et il
faut faire avec
[Musique]
red bull et la course par excellence
pour tester son courage et sa puissance
ne s'agit pas seulement d'être en forme
physiquement et techniquement en faut
aussi trouver le courage de faire
ski alpin demande beaucoup de courage
il faut être un grand skieur mais aussi
être capable de tout risquer pour finir
sur le podium ou dans le décor
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent c'est le top du
top pour un skieur on y retourne année
après année on la connaît par coeur
quand on va en russie ou en chine pour
les jeux olympiques on ne sait pas s
attendre on ne connaît pas bien la piste
et gagner est un peu un coup de chance
mais si on gagne kitzbuehl c'est qu'on
est le meilleur
[Musique]
on
se prépare toute l'année pour ça pour
qu'ils débutent alors se blesser juste
avant c'est vraiment dur
si on se met à hésiter à skier sur la
défensive alors lâche xiii prend le
contrôle fil des années on se rend
compte que si on veut garder le contrôle
sur cette piste il faut skier de manière
agressive et tout donné il faut savoir
se mettre en danger tout en gardant
contrôle ce qui rend la victoire aussi
importante c'est de savoir ce que l'on
risque si l'on perd le contrôle de la
course rien qu'une fraction de seconde
ce innove c'est très bien quel point ce
jeu peut-être dangereux
[Musique]
les lignes de départ et d'arrivée de la
strive où être les mêmes chaque année la
course n'est jamais deux fois la même
tout simplement parce qu'on skie sur de
la neige d'un jour à l'autre la
température peut changer et la course
devient complètement différent
c'est important de bien inspecter l'état
de la piste avant pour définir la
stratégie adoptée
un même virage peut être facile une
année extrêmement difficile la suivante
parce que notre vitesse y est beaucoup
plus élevé
c'est pourquoi il faut toujours se
demander à quelle vitesse on va arriver
en ce qui concerne les forces qui
s'exercent sur nous lorsque l'on ce
qu'il n'y a aucune limite c'est pour
cette raison que dans une chute on peut
rien maîtriser
impressionnant même pour moi c'est laid
c'est vrai ça fait trois ans que je
n'allais pas skier j'en ai presque peur
c'est pas vrai non je rigole mais c'est
impressionnant
oui c'est sûr
les fiancés ont loupé un virage on a
deux options soit on improvise et on se
remet difficilement sur la bonne
trajectoire soit on continue
d'improviser jusqu'au bout
et ça doit être une décision instinctive
on n'a qu'une fraction de seconde pour
l'apprendre
ce qui fait la différence sur cette
piste ce sont les années d'expérience
derrière soi mais
doit inspecter la pistache et c'est
regarder ce qui diffère de la veille
s'il ya plus de bosses et selon la ba
est plus difficile
plus on vérifie la piste plus on est
confiant il paye ses clés concrètement
l'objectif est de reproduire toutes nos
meilleures trajectoires en une seule et
même course
un script l'instinct et mon meilleur
allié cette
île juste atteint trop réfléchir on
risque de passer à côté de sa course on
n'a pas le temps de penser juste d'agir
si vous arrivez à faire ça vous pouvez
créer l'exploit et inscrit au ps
salut eric comment tu te sens bien j'ai
entendu dire que tu avais un problème au
dos crâne ne bouge nous je me le suis
bousiller à wengen
cette saison tu pense quand même que tu
vas pouvoir skier aujourd'hui
non je vais pas la descente c'est
dommage mais c'est comme ça
oui
on n'a qu'une descente d'entraînement
cette année alors je me suis dit qu'il
fallait que je donne tout pour voir de
quoi j'étais capable j'ai vraiment très
envie de gagner cette course
le parcours est quand même super même si
normalement la difficulté des
l'hausbergkante apporte quelque chose en
plus j'avais vraiment envie de skier
cette descente en donnant le maximum il
fallait que je le fasse je m'en serais
voulu si je n'avais pas tout donné
aujourd'hui pendant cette descente
d'entraînement
évidemment que je suis déçu de ne pas
pouvoir faire la course de kitzbuehl
je me suis préparé pour ça toute l'année
et j'ai failli gagner l'an passé
en même temps mon genou n'est pas en
état pour que je reprenne la compétition
et c'est hors de question de participer
à kitzbuehl quand on n'est pas au
meilleur de sa forme ça rend la
situation plus facile à accepter
et puis il ya toujours l'année prochaine
je pense que j'ai encore quelques belles
années devant moi je reviendrai
j'ai bien peur que les prévisions météo
soit encore mauvaise je sais que ces
derniers jours ont été dures mais
malheureusement ça ne va pas aller en
s'améliorant
tout comme moi vous avez grandi à
kitzbuehl
vous savez donc ce que cela veut dire il
faut s'attendre à beaucoup de neige
l'armée de réserve autrichienne est déjà
en route pour geeks bull
il va donc falloir que l'on s'occupe du
parcours jour et nuit pendant les
prochaines 48 heures
escada gâteau sans ça il n'y aura pas de
course
[Musique]
o les mélodies miller a fait un sacré
entraînements
il faut être agressif comme ça pour
gagner
mais en étant aussi agressif j'ai peur
pour mon dos
en m'entraînant cet été au col du
stelvio j'ai mal pris une bosse ça
m'avait lui des douleurs au dos pour le
reste de la saison
avant l'entraînement à kitzbühel tout
allait bien
j'espère que mon dos sera remis à temps
pour pouvoir faire la course est
excellent rien ne dois m'arrêter il faut
que jusqu'ici
non je suis autrichien je dois faire
lâche travail fdt
[Musique]
non
je sens que ça va bien se passer demain
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'ils sont prêts t'as plus qu'à bien
skié nous repose sur moi m'attend
demain ma part du boulot sera rempli ce
sera à toi de jouer on peut y arriver
c'est bien tu mets la pression j'en ai
besoin allez à demain
max j'espère que vous êtes tous près les
prochaines 24 heures vont être
difficiles
les barquettes de sauvetage sont prêtes
oui c'est bon elle sont prêtés
[Musique]
combien y at-il de souffleuses à neige
elles sont toutes à notre disposition
les gros souffleuse à neige tentent ici
et les petites sont sur le parcours
c'est bon aussi pour les équipes de
secours elles sont prêtes parfait yann
c'est très important on sait jamais la
nuit c'est toujours plus dangereux et vu
que c'est très glissant on a vite fait
de tomber
une fois la piste dégagée il n'y aura
plus qu'à réinstaller les finis
[Musique]
il ya deux autres personnes qui
veilleront sur vous de là haut st pierre
un tony tyler en fait il vous teste pour
voir de quoi vous êtes capables mais ne
vous inquiétez pas ils vérifieront que
tout se passe bien pour vous et vous
donneront un coup de main si vous en
avez besoin
[Musique]
ne vous en faites pas à tout se passera
bien
[Musique]
le jury se rendre à la ou à 7 heures ce
qui signifie que la piste devra être
dégagés avant
j'aimerais dire un grand merci et un
grand bravo directeur des pistes que
voici ainsi qu'à toute son équipe grâce
à eux le parcours est parfait
il n'y a plus qu'à espérer que la météo
soit bonne
[Musique]
l'ambiance satis bull est vraiment
spécial on sent que les employés et
volontaires ont travaillé dur pour que
la course soit un vrai spectacle peur de
quoi
[Musique]
e
parlant des milliers de personnes
viennent assister à cette course et en
tant que skieur pendant deux minutes
c'est à nous de faire une star c'est
quelque chose d'incroyable
l'énergie qui se dégage de cette foule
m'a toujours aidé à repousser mes
propres limites sacchetti pull
c'est grâce à ça que je me surpasse sur
la chtf les rechutes chez toqué
départ de la mostra le hockey
entrée du steinbach ok
une fois qu'on en arrive là haut au
départ la phase de concentration
commence
il ya des gens partout mais il faut
faire abstraction de tout ce qui se
passe autour et rester concentré le
secret c'est de garder la tête froide
sortie du style baroque est entré dual
touch mouse est ok les barquettes de
sauvetage sont en position
on est en train de les amener
[Musique]
yves peu importe que la course soit plus
ou moins difficile que les autres en
effet on essaie toujours de se surpasser
et d'être le plus rapide parce qu'on
veut gagner tout le monde est en
position on est prêt
[Musique]
le broyat s'intensifie au niveau de
leurs chaînes schultz on ne voit plus
qu'à une porte
[Musique]
ce ne sont pas toutes les chutes qui
fonde kitbul un vrai challenge et c'est
toute sa technicité
tout le monde est nerveux et tendu pas
seulement les skieurs leur équipe aussi
sont très secs
tout ce que l'on fait là au visa nous
préparer psychologiquement
il faut réussir être fort mentalement
pour être capable de tout donner pour
gagner une course qui nous fait peur
pour moi c'est ce qui fait la différence
entre l'âge traille fait les autres
courses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand on est sur la piste c'est une
bataille contre nous mêmes que l'on mène
c'est assez particulier puisqu'on est le
seul athlète sur la piste quand on skie
on se bat contre le parcours
tout ce parcours hockey toutes les
équipes sont en position
oui oui c'est bon on est prêt ok bonne
course à tous alors faites bien
attention à vous et soyez toujours prêts
à intervenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une fois qu'on sait lance dans la course
on n'a plus le droit à l'erreur
il faut trouver le bon équilibre
prendre les bons risques vont pouvoir
gagner
[Musique]
un descendeur se bat contre lui même
sens ils font se bat contre la course
est contre nous mêmes pour ne pas avoir
peur d'aller vite et fast su être
toujours plus agressif on se bat pas les
uns contre les autres on ne se compare
pas aux autres je sais tout ce que l'on
veut c'est être aussi rapide que
possible
et on encourage bien for you read and i
know de keane skieurs virus
je suis extrêmement nerveuse
avant l'entraînement j'ai même dû
prendre un verre de whisky
qu'est ce que c'est la dernière course
de la saison je dois donner le maximum
pour faire un bon résultat et améliorer
notre situation
[Musique]
cet exigeant c'est vraiment intense et
ça peut être dangereux aussi les
émotions se bousculent dans la peur et
en même temps on est excité moi je suis
là pour donner le meilleur de moi même
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les fêtards si on commence à douter de
soi le mieux à faire c'est de rentrer à
la maison
[Musique]
si vous n'êtes pas assez offensif c'est
la piste qui aura votre peau la
meilleure façon de s'en sortir c'est
d'être agressif et de viser la victoire
c'est quand on skie sur la défensive
qu'on se mette en danger
[Musique]
inquiète tout ce qui s'est passé à
kitzbuehl impose le respect si on
devient passif l'espace d'un instant
c'en est fini pour nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il restait aux commandes c'est ça le
plus important
oignies au portillon de départ on se
sent comme dans un tunnel
on entend le bipe comprend ses bâtons de
chaque côté et on s'élance
[Musique]
on se prépare pour ce moment au
portillon de départ où l'on s'apprête à
ce qu'ils aient la décence la plus
difficile de la coupe du monde
c'est la castille ça y est c'est à moi
de jouer je vais tout risquer pour
gagner
[Musique]
je pense que c'est sur cette course que
trouver un juste milieu est le plus
difficile
il faut savoir risque ni trop ni trop
tôt nous tous moches
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
on ne gagne pas la strive par hasard ça
prend des années pour la maîtriser tout
comme mes adversaires je veux la
remporter
[Musique]
dupuis il faut décider d'une trajectoire
et la suivre tant bien que mal et
surtout faire en sorte de ne jamais
inchangé
[Musique]
les bosses sont d'une violence telle que
ça devient difficile de voir où l'on va
et de rester concentré sur sa
trajectoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant de m'élancer j'avais mal une
demi-heure plus tôt je me tenais appuyé
sur mes bâtons car c'était la seule
position dans laquelle je n'avais mal
nulle part
ac mais juste là devant moi il y avait
la mostra de fans ce n'était pas le
moment de laisser la douleur prendre le
dessus
delos je m'étais dit que si j'arrivais à
passer la compression sans trop de
douleur je tenterai le tout pour le tout
vol
mrs
[Musique]
youmzain faut tout faire pour conserver
sa vitesse de départ
ne jamais la perdre
[Musique]
il
si on a le malheur de prendre la moindre
petite bosse de travers ne pense plus
qu'à une seule chose rester en vie tout
ce que l'on espère c'est terminé la
course en vie
rien de plus
[Musique]
regardez
c'est évidemment
[Musique]
thomas que ce soit à cause d'un virage
pris trop large ou bien parce que l'on
dévie un peu si on perd de la vitesse on
le sent immédiatement le sinn speed
et alors on prend le risque de se
refaire
et on prend la trajectoire la plus
dangereuse et et on ne se trouve plus à
un mètre mais à 10 cm tu fais
si on a le courage de prendre ce risque
tout n'est plus qu'une question de la
confiance en soi de centrales
[Musique]
jara
[Applaudissements]
cette au moment de retirer mes skis que
je me suis rendu compte de l'ampleur des
dégâts j'avais tellement mal tout le
monde m'applaudissaient mais j'avais du
mal à me réjouir j'ai pris sur moi
je ne voulais pas montrer à quel point
je souffrais
notre sport est merveilleux sommet à ce
moment là ce que je ressentais était
tout sauf merveilleux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des années pour apprendre à connaître la
sht ralph
white nisus j'ai voulu prendre un risque
mais j'ai fait une grosse erreur et j'ai
failli faire une chute j'ai eu de la
chance
j'ai beau être biélorusse je
n'abandonnerai pas je reviendrai et je
ferai tout pour rejoindre le top 10
gagner ici c'est ce que je veux et je
suis prêt à tout pour y arriver
[Musique]
les prix
et maintenant
le vainqueur de kitzbühel
allez
à l'échelle
[Applaudissements]
reporter qui pullulent à descendre en
gamme et se retrouver face à 25 mille
fans survoltés qui répète sans cesse
votre nom tout ça c'est juste incroyable
[Applaudissements]
j'ai gagné la descente danone calmes et
peu après je n'avais plus aucune douleur
j'ai senti que quelque chose n'allait
pas
comme tu peux le voir l'hernie discale
est maintenant bien visible la situation
a empiré il va falloir opérer ce serait
bien de faire ça aujourd'hui
et si je continue de ski et
d'un point de vue médical c'est
absolument hors de question ça pourrait
avoir des conséquences dramatiques sur
ta jambe continuer de ce qui est serait
complètement irresponsable
l'a donc j'arrête c'est ça
pour la saison pour toute la saison
après la course que j'ai réalisé à
kitzbuehl l'an passé j'étais très
frustré honnêtement je pense que j'étais
le meilleur j'ai juste fait les
mauvaises erreur
[Musique]
mais j'y retournerai et je skierai de
façon encore plus agressive c'est le
genre de course qu'on veut absolument
dans son palmarès
développement le groupe nord est un
endroit idéal pour se recentrer
l'engrais que fait un terran données
permet de réfléchir et quand on se pose
là haut et qu'on regarde tout ça on se
fixe de nouveaux objectifs et remportez
kitzbuehl 10 l'inde émerge
[Musique]
limite la pêche s'il faut être patient
un jour tout finira par se réaliser et
j'espère que ce jour n'est pas trop loin
[Musique]
avoir une cabine à mon nom même titre
que des skieurs tels que eberharter et
maier
c'est un rêve d'enfant devenu réalité
mais voilà maintenant en compagnie de
légendes
c'est vraiment super
[Musique]
salut tu as aksel lund svindal oui et
toi
je m'appelle linus et un jour j'aimerais
descendre la streif comme toi
je vais redescendre la strife aussi et
je veux la gagner
didier quand on y repense c'était
vraiment une descente aux enfers à les
descendants cette petite pointe on y va
4 3 2 1 partez
[Musique]